نقول وبكل اسف وبكل الم اننا اصبحنا في جز
الدفاع المدني عاجزين عن القيام باداء
مهامنا والقيام بالمهام الموكله الينا من
حمايه ارواح المواطنين وانقاذهم للاسف
الشديد لا يوجد لدينا سوى مركبه واحده
قريده الخدمه الان مركبه الانقاد الوحيده
التي تعرضت للقصف في قبل حوالي اسبوعين تم
اصلاحها بجهود ذاتيه وبجهود كبيره لا نقول
الا اننا مستمرون سنبقى يستمرون في ادا
خدمتنا لا يمكن ان نغادر المكان لا يمكن
ان نغادر الميدان لا يمكن ان نغادر مكان
عملنا اين انتم من حمايه جهاز الدفاع
المدني اين انتم من توفير الامكانيات
اللازمه لجهاز الدفاع المدني اين انتم من
توفير المركبات المطلوبه للعمل في جهاز
الدفاع المدني وتوفير الحمايه التي وثقتها
كل مواثيق واعراف وقوانين العالم
الحر